so we're thrilled to have with us today
dr. pablo simone more de who is a
professor at University of Granada in
Spain and he is also a member of the
national bioethics Commission of Spain
and he is here at Columbia's visiting
professor for a few months and we're
very fortunate to have him here he as a
physician works on end-of-life care
issues and of course and the life here
is very important as we know from sarah
palin's comments about death panels and
president obama's of a new electric
President Obama's Affordable Care Act
and his initial plan to encourage
doctors to talk about advanced care
planning that was taken off the table
but these are mainly big big issues and
every country deals with it differently
and so it's very important to see how
other countries deal with these issues
and so we're honored and thrilled to
have dr. Lourdes with us today
so thank you so much firstly I want to
give thanks to Professor Wiseman for
this opportunity to serve with you well
the development of end-of-life
decision-making in Spain I mean this is
important topic that should be also
features for you because you can compare
what we are doing and how we are dealing
with these problems with the situation
in the u.s. so I mean it will be
interesting for you secondly i also want
to to say that i am also very grateful
to professor Ron buyer that is well now
i am working on public health ethics so
we're moving from clinic clinical ethics
to public health ethics that is a
different topic and in fact i am here
because he agree to meet me as a
visiting professor here and finally i
want to say that any a bit anxious
because i am a bit shy and because i
think that you're a very clever and
intelligent people know in a lot about
bioethics because I mean that my English
is not so good so I am a bit worried
about this but I will try to do the best
trying to communicate use and ideas
about how is this topic in in Spain
first of all I want to say that probably
probably you know that the spain is a
member of the european union we are
about 46 million people we are a
parliamentary monarchy like many other
countries in europe this is a political
system quite special but this is the
reality and i have to say that and this
is important for my my my talk because
in fact spain now is a quasi federal
state because we are divided in 17
regions that will have a I mean quite a
lot of autonomy for many decisions well
our surfaces similar is between texts
in California so we are not a very big
country but we are one of them of the
biggest countries in Europe we have
until now a national health care system
quite similar to web to what you are
going with Obamacare I'm not sure about
that but this is what we have until now
because the new government is
introducing reforms for example for the
universal coverage that until now was
around the ninety-nine percent of the
people was coverage by the shtetl system
that is financed by taxes and but also
it's at the same time decentralized
sampled at the health curve in the 17
regions around the 99 percent of our
DDPs this with cost of the health care
so it's not it's not very high I mean
it's quite is in the median of the
European countries our results in I mean
that our results in terms of health are
quite good our fertility rate is quite
low but the life expectancy is very high
is probably one of the highest in Europe
about 83 years old for women and 76 year
for men the main causes cause of death
of diseases of the circulatory system
the malignant neoplasm and the disease
of the respiratory system quite similar
to most of the developed countries so i
have given you I sorry i have given you
this case this case it's not a european
case is not the spanish cases is a
catchment United step is quite old it
was you sued in in the German in 1988 I
mean that you have had the opportunity
to read it and well this this case when
it was used in the Yama produced a great
debate with a lot of letters
discussing the case so well you have the
paper and you can read in the paper but
if you have got the opportunity to read
it I would like to ask you to try to put
a name to name this axiom what is this
internal this in turn is doing what God
is doing this doctor and here you have a
list of things so those you have three
the case what do you think I know this
is right but um I will call it
euthanasia after you that I feel well ok
I think in this case and adding i'm in
favor of positions of the suicide but i
think in this case it was homicide
homicide okay all right ears
yep I'll call palliative sedation
palliative sedation what it is okay okay
I'm just getting you cancel white
quickly read through it but I look like
a similar thing to be here in hospice
care today hospice care palliative care
I mean yeah ok do it going good clinical
practice at the end I've in a good
clinical practice for you um for me
personally I need to research what the
effects of morphine are on my conscious
state but i think it's okay and i think
it is okay good so well it's enough you
can think but you can see active
euthanasia homicide palliative sedation
good clinical practice for different
names with four different ethical
dimensions and legal consequences so
this is the problem I mean you also have
the problem death panels interpretate it
as for me from Europe do the panel's of
the Obamacare were advanced care
planning but for the Republicans were
death panels euthanasia so this is the
problem with which we are we have been
fighting in Spain and Europe I am mean
that also in the United State is about
the names of the things of the actions
because behind the names there are moral
decisions or a legal consequences about
this so in fact we have been having a
debate in Spain about these topics since
the 40 years and between also you know
that we have a civil war and we have
dictatorship
between nineteen forty and ninety
seventy eight when democracy arrived in
Spain we also had debate about these
points but of course the most important
of the last name i'm going to explain
you how was the debate about how to
differentiate these and which are the
moral consequences and the legal
consequences of to these different
actions i am going to speak about law
and then i have to say that although i
am going to speak about legal
regulations in fact i am not a lawyer I
are not interested in levy loss but loss
behind the laws there are ethical
decisions values and ethical
considerations that this is the point
that I am interested in in fact not in
the not in the law but in what what is
behind the law so although I am going to
speak a lot about law I in fact I will
be speaking about ethics this is
important you know that a for sample in
southern Europe in the countries of the
Latin area low is very important because
regulations self-regulation ethical
regulation has been not well developed
so many times we develop regulations did
it directly through the law well one
very important point was a constitution
the constitution includes the
constitutional right to life and to not
suffer unit you inhuman or degrading or
they order graydon treat and this was
very important because you can see here
there are two sides of the of the way of
the right the right to life but also the
right not to suffer inhuman or degrading
trade and the other very important value
right was the constitutional right to
freedom and the free development of the
persons of this values these
constitutional rights are behind many of
our debates how to balance these two
values and there is a very important
and decision of the Constitutional Court
that is exactly the same to your Supreme
Court because this this discord is a has
to interpretate the Constitution about a
very important hunger style that we
suffer in the in the 90s in Spain it was
a hungry type of prisoners that were
members of a terrorist group named
grapple and the debate was if we have to
enforce the feeding of the prisoners to
neutral them to die so that was the
debate and the conclusion of the
constitution of the court was that there
is a right to life but there is not an
obligation to life this is important
because open the door to the refusal of
treatment and this not obligation to
life is protected also by the right to
freedom and this for all the citizens in
general but not for prisoners does it
there is an exception with prisoners
because the prisoners are under the
protection of the state and so there is
also a cat in the development of this
right so they can be enforced to fit in
now so there is a general but also there
is an exception with prisoners I have to
say that this I disagree with this but
this is not the case now so but this was
very important in the 90s well
previously in 1986 we had the first sort
of rights of the patients you have here
in the states the first child were
developing around the 70s but we had to
wait until 1986 to find this in Spain
for example this not included all the
question of informed consent the refusal
of treatment but not including for
example nothing about living wills
about advance directives and this is
very important it was not very clear
about substitute decision making so this
was a great problem but at least we had
the first start dealing with these
aspects that were complete I have to say
that were completely unknown in the
hospitals because the atmosphere in the
Spanish hospitals at this time was very
paternalistic so it was quite new to
introduce the right to informed consent
in the hospitals in Spain well in 1995
arise a new panel code and this was very
important because for end of life
because it was a new article the article
in 143 of the new penal code that in the
4 paragraph introduces a regulation of a
special type of axioms you can see the
first says is regulating regulating the
induction to suicide this is a criminal
a criminal axiom the second is
regulating their a cooperation the third
is very strange is very strange because
as well so how can I cooperate written
the level of producing the death so how
can I suicide other so it's really
strange but most important is the fourth
because not using not not using the word
euthanasia it was describing what what
most of us interpretate has interpreted
as euthanasia so direct us to the death
of another person by disperse request
serious and an equivocal of this one in
case the victim suffered a serious
disease that would let necessarily to to
his her death or that produce serious
suffering permanent and difficult to
support will be punished with it and
this is the point with inferior
intense prison so it is a criminal act
but it's not a serious as others so this
is the reason why they punish is slower
is lower than others so this was very
important because well first in fact
this article in Spain has with only
apply one time one time and it was in
2009 it was really an act of a Vanessa
by this doctor but I had to say that the
great debate in Spain was about what is
regulating regulating this article
because for many people is just was
referred to what we call euthanasia
active direct and voluntary acts for but
for many other people is what knows it
was not so clear that also can be
included in the article other things
like pasi filter nasiha dealing with
emissions the debatable with Hall
withdrawal what we call now limitation
of it you say futile of future it okay
fatale treatments the indirect
euthanasia that now we call police
sedation of even the copier cooperation
with society debate in spain from 1995
and till 2010 and later we will see why
this this year has been dealing with
this problem not only in Europe we have
not only in Spain we have this problem
because for example here you have a
resolution of the Council of Europe that
is a very important is European
institution and you can see is this is a
very important resolution about advance
directives and living wheels and you can
see different solution is not intending
to deal with the use of euthanasia or
assisted suicide and then gives a
definition euthanasia in the sense of
the intentional killing by act or
omission
really i don't know how can you kill
others fire missile because if you if
you are telling me that he is refusing
the treatment so this is the reason why
you are not giving the treatment then
this is a refusal of treatment and
that's all and and if you are not giving
the treatment and you should be given
the treatment because it is well
indicated then this is not an orphan
answer by omission if is not good
clinical practice even you can say this
is an herbicide or but not euthanasia I
or museum so this is the problem we have
with with words well in Spain there is a
very important case that open the
debates to all the society because until
now this was mainly a question a debate
of lawyers special moral philosophers
doctors but this case open the debate
you all the society you know the name of
this guy his Ramon Sampedro probably you
don't know him but if I put this son of
you have you watched this movie okay the
sea inside yo haba birthday no he's so
handsome so this is the story of Ramon
Sampedro so Ramon Sampedro well Bertha
was a person that he was a quadriplegic
what we shall you say quadriplegic he
was paralyzed but he was not dependent
of mechanical ventilation this was
important he was completely capable and
at one moment he asked I want to die and
I need help to die so please allow some
doctor to give me some drug to produce
me the death this was the point and it
was a great event in Spain well the
debate was so intense that at the end
produced a movie so it was very
important but I always say that in this
in this picture for me the important
persons of course is he and there are
over very important persons in this
picture are these who are them the press
the journalists because this was the
first time that this was a very intense
debate in Spain about this topic so you
know what that have watched the movie
you know that at the end he commits
suicide because he even he even he he
produced a video that is later you can
see it how his dying is terrible the
video okay in 1996 it was passed this is
important if you if you want to
understand some of the things that are
happening around bioethics in Europe you
have to you have to read this very
important document because we call it
the odlo convention because it's the it
is the ways the basement for the
development development of many
regulation on bio ethical question
clinical and also research questions in
Europe so Spain ratify the Convention on
january of two thousand and it was very
important because this convention when
you sign and ratify the Convention as
can't reader of life to adapt delegate
legislation to the content of this
convention so we had to introduce
changes in our law for example in the
chart of rights of patients of 19 of
1986 we were obliged to do this for
sample to introduce advanced directives
and proxy and proxy decision-making so
the result was a new law that is very
important because now is the main law
regulating many decisions many clinical
decisions in Spain and this law
introduced well clearly again informed
consent the right to refuse
it ma'am but also putting clear the 62
decision making the proxy
decision-making and things like like
advance directives I am going to tell
you some things about proxy decision
making because I mean it's important to
show you that the situation i mean the
situation in Spain now is quite similar
to the United States so these nerve
regulate three situations in which we
have to do proxy concern is the first of
all is what I have translated is
incapable de facto so I don't know how
is this here is he is now incapable
incapable the fact to you use this
expression yes okay incapable the fact
the second is a legally incapacitated
patient this is this needs a judge that
a court decision and the third is a
minor not mature but well we have
problems with this well in these
situations who decides well in the first
if advance directive exists then the
designated proxy this and in second term
the family if there is no advance
directive then is the family for sample
I I know why I remember that 10 years
ago i was reading the New York State
task force that was regulating this and
now it's quite similar to what the
situation in Spain well in the case of a
leg Ally incapacitated you say the tutor
know how is the the person that is
designated by the judge to decide how is
the name of this in English The Guardian
I was thinking the world I'm sorry okay
and mine on the parents okay well I how
the sides well the law only speaks about
two criteria so the first is the advance
directive or subjective standard so the
result back an advance directive you
have to follow the instructions of the
advance directive
even joy the proxy but this load doesn't
regulate the substitute judgment
standard there is no mention in this
load to this and introduce the best
interest standard so if there is no
possibility to know to know the desires
of the decisions of the patient then we
have to apply what is well mention the
best interest standard I mean that you
also in the u.s. use this is important
because for example you know that United
Kingdom the United Kingdom below in fact
only applies the best interest standard
so at the end if there is no advance
directive directly the family can sorry
we have to establish the best if the
interest standard but in the UK who is
really deciding what is the best
interest is not the family are the
doctors by law so I mean in the UK in
the United Kingdom remains a sort of
paternalism in this area that is really
surprising now in the development of the
of the British society well also
disloyal tradition the advanced I
directors they are written documents
they made by competent persons of legal
aids well they are done to express
wishes to express wishes and relating in
relation with the destiny of the body of
the organelles and to appoint a proxy
quite similar to the United States I
mean but this is important point because
there are many difference in Europe
around is in many European countries now
there are advanced directives but there
are a lot of differences about the
binding effect of these documents for
example in France advanced directives
really are not binding for doctors
they can discuss the content of that
advanced directive and but in Spain they
can there are some exceptions if they
are against the law for example a
patient has put I want euthanasia and
allow the decision at the India binds
dialectal you cannot follow this because
this is in the Criminal Code so this is
a criminal action you can a doctor
cannot do that is not obliged to do that
should be to be without sense to do that
if this is important for the discussion
about futility that we will we will look
at after if they are contrary to the leg
scientists good clinical practice so
this is an exception that's half two
sides because you can do a very
paternalistic interpretation of this but
it's also an open door to discuss about
futility cases when for example here you
know the one bleep case in the United
States the Wankel case is a case here
you had this case in which a woman had
put in the advanced directive I want
everything forever and this one to court
I don't I don't know the state so this
is a problem because which is the
violence between the designs of the
patients in advance directive of the
opinion of the doctors about futility of
some things this is an open door here in
Spain to this well in the case if the
case is not clearly describing the
document but may be freely revoked and
in Spain we have registries so if you do
an advance directive then you have to
put in a registry this is in fact in
Spain out there are 70 registers but
they are coordinated so they are in fact
they are their files and disallow as to
know exactly the number of advanced
directives that there are in Spain they
are very few
very low so the use of advanced
directives in the spine is very low this
is that yesterday a'right me that they
gave me the last number is November 2012
exactly that number very very low very
low why because probably in Spain even
today although we have on these
regulations most of the persons prefer
to live the decision in the hands of the
family and that's all so one problem
with this law of 2002 the capacity has
to be evaluated by the attending doctor
of the Bayesian who can consult other
colleagues usually psychiatrists but
there is no criteria no criteria in the
Lord to guide the decision so it's
completely open this is a decision by
the professionals okay d was a situation
in 2002 well the debate was how to apply
how so how to use all these this law to
decide in end-of-life cases this was the
debate in Spain and it was not so clear
but there was a lot of interest at after
Rama Ramon Sampedro case the interest in
in this in in Spain about end-of-life a
decision has been very very high very
very high for example we all the Spanish
people follow it completely the case of
terrible so the impact of the tablet see
a bookcase in Spain was very high was
very high and the debate was really in
the indie journals the gel every day we
had news about what how is going on the
case of tarisha in the United States so
every every day
we had news about this and for example
there was an important debate about this
movie do you remember this movie this
movie this is a movie Million Dollar
Baby and you know that at the end of the
movie if you have not watched the movie
you should at the end of the movie that
is an act that is an euthanasia not
exactly later we will see why but and so
this was also very commented in in Spain
but then we had really our first on
second on important case the first was
Ramon Sampedro the second was this this
was a hospital hospital severo ochoa
laganas this is a small city close to
Madrid and then the doctors they were
doing palliative sedation and then there
was they were sued they weren't should
buy some persons and they were sued
because they told that they were
committing euthanasia again the problem
of the world's and it was very important
debate with deep consequence because it
reduces that palliative sedation that
was at the beginning it was not very
very used in Spain until that moment
then many doctors became scared of the
use of palliative sedation and they
began not to do palliative sedation and
you can see it was three years of debate
about this case at the end they were not
found that the doctors were not found
guilty so on the court decided that it
was fine it was good clinical practice
we have also music concerts to support
this this is the well the consulate but
this is a main case this is the third
important case and you will see that it
is quite similar to some of your cases
this is the case of Immaculate seborrhea
well this case is interesting because
immaculate seborrhea live in Granada in
the city where I am so was a woman with
progressive muscular dystrophy with Anna
spinal atrophy and he was dependent of
mechanical ventilation what moment so
they having a mechanical ventilation
since 1997 until two thousand and seven
six and then she decide to ask the with
level of the mechanical ventilation but
using again the problem with the words
using the world euthanizing euthanasia
so she said I want to be sedated and
disconnected of the mechanical
ventilation I want euthanasia so she's
not obliged to use correctly the world
but you can imagine so how when this
arrived to papers and begins again the
debate mm well she was completely
capable her capacity was evaluated by
two independent psychiatrists and and
then she asked well she refused the
treatment well this case went to the
regional value of his comedian andalusia
i was there i was one of the member and
our opinion as committee is that the
immaculada request is not euthanasia her
request is just the treatment refusal a
revocation of consent to receive
mechanical ventilation and the with
level of mechanical ventilation is not
contrary to ethics at the request of a
patient acting freely well informed and
with enough capacity to decide then also
there is another body that was the the
Ministry of Health regional Ministry of
Health send the case to the to the
bioethics committee and other body that
is this one
is a body of consultation about legal
questions well it is the members of this
body additionally are very academic
important professors of law that the
physicians are no binding but if this
body says we don't find any problem with
this then probably there will be no
problem in the in the legal area so they
said immaculada request of with our wall
of the mechanical ventilation is not
contrary to law a health care
professionals who will disconnect the
ventilation shouldn't be prosecuted so
this was the decision it this was very
important so in maculata were sedated
and disconnected from the mechanical
ventilation also as you can see here in
United States with a lot of people in
the front of the hospital with shouting
life and all this well you know all this
questions it was exactly the same in
Spain and welt impact of this case in
the journals was very important in Spain
for sampled el pais you know el pais is
the main journal of Spain in fact it is
they have an agreement within year times
and many of the things that the New York
Times is usually in the they are also
used within the in del pas and and so
on and it wasn't very intense debate in
Spain about about this case and many
valleys give their opinion for example
this is very important because this was
the Catholic Church this was an center
of the catalytic catholic university of
valencia and debate the debate was
exactly the same as ever so immaculate
saawariya euthanasia or limitation
limitation of treatment so again the
same
do you know this case this case of this
of the last month in queens you know so
this is a situation quite similar to
Immaculate seborrhea but this this woman
had I mean if she had a brain tumor she
was probably almost terminal and in a
moment she decided to be disconnected of
the mechanical ventilation and he
canceled a debate about if if she was
not capable to decide and if hired the
size were this or not but at the end I
don't know if you have watched this
video it is injured in YouTube just said
what's it because this is a soft video
what a cuisine of this girl of this
woman is asking her desires but do you
want to designate your father that this
is a very important priest and the
father of this woman very important
please that is against the disconnection
of of the mechanical ventilation he's
asking her but why don't you agree with
designating your father as your proxy
and finally the woman says jersey as yes
I agree I agree so I don't want to be
disconnected and this have been employed
in the court so to not to disconnect
this woman but if you watch the video I
mean it's quite a scary because the way
a her cuisine is asking her I don't know
if she is completely free should-should
interesting if you can watch the video
you can see the
okay this is just to put that the cases
are quite similar debates an hour are
quite similar well into in 2007 I am
going on so you can see this was very
important because one of the device
usually in end-of-life decision is about
well you are you are talking about of
these but you have not supporting people
really because you are not giving them
Gopal a good palliative curve so the
question of palliative care is always on
the table and in 2007 the Federal
Minister of Health developed the first
plan to develop put on the first plan to
develop the palliative care in all Spain
many regions have developed a palliative
care but this was a coordinated action
to develop palliative care in all the
regions on state now the situation I
mean five years later is quite good I
can I have to say that palliative care
now means in Spanish why developed and
it's quite similar probably not as good
as in the United Kingdom or valium or
Denmark or the Netherlands but I mean
it's quite quite good because we
continue to debate this until the end
but at least in all this process the
Spanish society has reached a point that
I mean it's interesting is in this list
we can separate separate these two
axioms to the other they are not the
same this axioms well come you can say
that can be regulated but this basic law
but it's not very clear because they the
immaculada let's have a real case shows
that it was not so clear which are the
differences between refusal of treatment
limitation of treatment how to apply the
right to refuse is what's not so clear
but given a siesta teanna sister she
shall we can say that is clearly
regulated by the Penal Code and this is
a decision of the central parliament but
sand regional Parliament's decided that
because the regulation of this area's
was not so clear was not so clear this
area's was not so clear in this law they
could develop their own laws and this
was made first time by Andalusia
Andalusia this regime who had suffered
the case of Immaculate seborrhea and the
debate of new of this guy decided to put
in force this this law to regulate of
all these areas the law this law of
Andalusia do some important questions
for example gives a clear definition of
God should be named euthanasia and you
can answer for this law are axioms that
has these conditions they casted all of
patients that is directly and
intentionally by means of a singly
mediated k cause cause effect
relationship are carry out and expects
an informant request repeated over time
of competent patients are carried out in
a context of suffering considerate and
acceptable by the patient due to an
incurable disease that has not been
successfully mitigated by other means
for example by palliative care and I
perform my health care professional so
this law thinks that euthanasia is a
typical thing typical axiom of
professionals this is the reason why for
example in Spain we would not say that
the action you can see in the movie a
million dollar baby is not exactly a new
venecia because it is done by the friend
of the of the main character of the of
the woman but the other conditions for
example the action Million Dollar Baby
really past is dis conditions and the
law says in light of this criteria no
vaccine should be labeled euthanasia
unless they fall into the preceding
categories refusal of treatment
limitation of method for life support
and palliative sedation should not
however will regret regarded as acts of
euthanasia the term does not appear in
the current criminal code however
article this article of South code does
include mention of the situation for a
form of aided or in usage suicide by
means of an exception exceptional
subcategory the law of of andalusia does
not regulate euthanasia so the law of
andalusia is not regulating with
regulating euthanasia but I have to say
that euthanasia is something that now in
Spain has a considerable support by the
people for example this is an opinion
poll of job of the dumb people of
between these years and you can see for
example regardless of what you could
personally do tell me whether you are
for or against helping a terminally ill
person to die if they ask for it
therefore the seventy-six percent of the
term people but in the general poles of
general population today in Spain around
sixty percent of the purp of the people
good support a legal regulation of
euthanasia for some clinical situations
but the support of assisted suicide is
around its lower surround forty percent
weight is difference because I mean that
Indian assist in the United States
should be is exactly the concert
a now here the support of uterine
euthanasia soso but in fact you have two
states the half baths regulation of
assisted suicide and why the difference
I think it we put a bigger emphasis on
Asami in the US I'm so like with
assisted suicide or making this early
Earth like that before someone's helping
you do it as opposed to euthanasia
they're doing to you yeah I mean I mean
this is the point so in the United
States for you the consideration of
autonomy is so important than do you
have to preserve abbr tana me until the
end so you have to take the drugs so if
you are taking the drugs this is your
problem this is your decision and some
aspects but in Europe this is not so
important so because we have to consider
but many for example in Spain many many
people should be scared about about the
idea of taking the drugs by their own so
they prefer the help of a health curve
but here in the states not you prefer to
preserve the freedom and the autonomy
until the end this is a warranty of this
as a sister she say I mean this is the
difference and i have to say that
probably many people in spain really
doesn't understand clearly what is
assisted suicide i have to say also this
well
andalusia started but then to other
regions have developed similar laws and
a draft of a basic law a federal law was
prepared and went to the Parliament in
2011 but then we went on elections and
so now this draft probably the new
government that is a conservative goblin
is has decided not to continue with the
debate of this draft so probably the
regulation this type of regulations
probably will remain in these three
regions for a lot of time and we will
not have a federal regulation I mean it
is a pity but this is the situation so
of all the contents I am going just to
refer to this point because I mean this
is the most interest and you can
probably the debate about what is
futility is quite similar we have the
same problems that you have probably I
am going to try to show you this before
for example the andalusia before that
the law is law this is the law from the
Lucia and do some important questions
for example includes criteria to
stablish the capacity of people and if
you if you are familiar with the dis
criteria standards you will find
something interesting if the patient has
so you have to evaluate if the patient
has difficulty in comprehending
information I am going to leave this if
the patient does not use information in
a logical way during the decision-making
process if the patient fails to
appreciate the possible outcome of
different alternatives and if the
patient is unable to milk to make a
final decision
some idea about where this criteria
coming from are you familiar with the
standards to evaluate capacity of
patients now this hardly create the
standards of upper bound this this this
and this these are the more famous are
more important standards to evaluate
capacity that we have and we have also
add this one that it deals with memory
this comes from the law of the United of
the United Kingdom so we have five
standards now in andalusia to evaluate
capacity of patients but a starting
point with utility I am going I am
ending my presentation question is a
doctoral black ethically legally to
withdraw a treatment with C considers
futile for the recovery of keys help
ASEAN when it is refused by a competent
patient and competent pacing with an
advanced directive where you see refuses
the treatment or the proxy family of an
incompetent without advance directive if
he obliged to withdraw yes or no your
opinion I mean it's quite clear the
doctor thinks it is futile and the
patient doesn't want so I say okay this
is easy I mean although some doctors can
have problems with this because they
think that for example if the point is
to disconnect a mechanical ventilation
damn thing but this is producing death
so although i think it's not indicated
and the patient doesn't want it i cannot
do that so we can have problems with
this but in general now it's clear a
little thing but what about this
it's not a pure black ethically and
legally to withdraw our treatment with C
considered futile for the recovery of
kiss her patient but is asked by a
competent pacing and incompetent person
with an advanced I direct the world here
see us for the treatment or the proxy
family of an incompetent without advance
I directive what could you say yes so oh
I don't know I'm going to the come to
the Ethics Committee yes yes you talk
you talk and you and you and you use all
your tools your communicative and
emotional tools to trying to convince
that okay this is not so easy third it's
a doctor obliged naegele to initiate a
treatment which she considers futile for
the recovery of peaceful placing when
the treatment is refused by a competent
basin and incompetent with an advisor
well he refused on the proxy yes or no
quite clear no in Spain this is now very
clear
the last it's a door tour of like
ethically need to initiate a feature of
your time treatment when the treatment
is passed by a competent person and
incompetent place in the data so i think
it's not indicated but they are asking
me to put the treatment what did you say
i think no but it should be a troubling
question for many people yeah
no yeah which I am going to take what i
am trying to show you is that this is
all the problems we have and the low in
andalusia novel runner i want to trying
to give more clear answers to these to
help the doctors to feel safe when they
are taking these decisions so this is
the point so the law is saying you can
decide you can decide even I am going to
say a strong question against the
desires of a patient or against the
opinion of a family if you clearly
consider that this is a futile treatment
this is the point that the law of
andalusia is putting on the table but
this off is also your problem so we
recommend this is a very interesting
paper is the major clinical proceedings
of one month ago I mean so very good
very good Israel is discussing 22 cases
of the United States the castle barneys
bounce and the castle of baby Joseph do
you remember the case of baby maybe just
Joseph this was a small child in Canada
and they came here because you don't
know where this is this is very
important because it is about proxy
decision-making in case of futility so
important well what what is doing the
andalucian love you sign this first is
given a definition what is this
limitation of therapeutic efforts is the
term that is very common in in in Europe
and in Spain I prefer limitation of
futile treatment this is the term and
the most important question comes here
so the decisions about futility are
decisions that are taken by the
clinicians
this is the first important question so
also as well son definition and this is
also important because this is a term
that is I mean that in the United States
is not is not usual but is very useful
in Europe and is very useful in Spain
Filippetti obstinacy do you know what's
this is completely exactly the opposite
what is the saying that not not limited
to not withdraw a with whole futile
treatment so is exactly what what is
happening when a doctor when a doctor is
using treatments that are futile okay
this is the the term that that we use
and this is the article that is
regulating the limitation of treat the
limitation of a futile treatment and you
can see how strong are the words because
says the doctor in charge of each spasm
must engage in good clinical practice by
limiting their telekinetic efforts when
the clinical situation so dictates
avoiding therapeutics obstinacy must set
limitation must be justified in the
clinical record such limitation shall be
exercised after seeking the professional
opinion of the nurse in search of the
patient and must be seconded by at least
one other physician involved in the
patient's care why this because the
problem with with utility is is that can
be very subjective so this is a
mechanism to save the subjectivity of
the judgment about futility
because I can decide oh I mean this is
not working put it off but this is not
the point how is how is this law
regulating this I have to say that to
write this we read a lot the Texas
regulation ok well the names of these
professionals together with their
opinion shall we entered into the
clinical record now let us the attending
physician together with other healthcare
personnel caring for the patient are
required to provide any health care
interventions needed to warranty the
patient's care and comfort and also
there is an article about health care
ethics committees if disagreements arise
the healthcare ethics committee I am
jumping may propose and this is the
difference with the Texas regulation
because for the you know for the Texas
regulation the decision of the ethics
committee is binding but we consider
that the decisions of that this
committee are not binding what is
finding really is the decision of the
professionals when divers when they are
doing internal process that should be
something like this evaluate the
clinical situation including premises
and effectiveness of the life-support
Mercer's evaluate the opinion of the
patient and the proxies Splore values
the size beliefs feelings check the
opinion of the nurse team check the
opinion of the other doctors decide if
in your opinion it is a case of utility
get a concurring opinion of a half of at
least order doctor communicate your
decision to the patient family proxies
give the opportunity to express express
opinions on feelings give time negotiate
progressive steps for with our walls but
putting in clear that the treatments
will be with wrong proceed with the
limitation produce
all the process in the clinical red
record this is the normal process and in
case of conflict give more time more
information more emotional support
consult the healthcare ethics committee
but the decision of the committee is not
binding in all the health care if all
the health care professionals and ethics
committee agree with the futility
judgment then you can proceed you do not
need to go to court although the patient
or the proxies can do so this is what
this law is regulating the futility how
this law regulating the futility
decisions so the idea should be to be
able to change these into this so this
would be the idea to give support the
doctors that are doing this well this is
my last slide what is Andalusia doing
now well under Luciano is doing research
asking this because well law is a can be
a interesting tool but there is no
warranty that this tool will help to get
better with the quality of the curve on
our life decisions so we are doing we
are doing because I involved in cell
research about this and also we have
developed this because we think that law
is an important tool but it is not
enough so we have done on when we call a
strategic plan of bioethics for the
entire region trying to help doctors
nurses patients ethics committees
families to be more and more involved in
the vaio ethic debate and in the biotic
deceit bioethics decision-making so we
think that probably also this will help
to increase the quality of death in
Andalusia but
I cannot give you no results about this
but I hope to do it for coming months
even years invite you to come too or
another I don't know if you you have
been there so we have a very interesting
monument this is the Alhambra Palace and
we have mountains with the snow this is
a palace built by the Muslims in the
13-14 century and is 1 and n is the most
visited monument in Spain so I know that
many of you when you go to spend you go
to Madrid or Barcelona okay okay fine
it's fine but it's important to come to
Granada and to visit me ok questions
slowly a lot of questions um your case
of Immaculata in Spain I'd looked like
she'd been on a ventilator for eight
years the woman and I was just wondering
if there was something specific that
occurred that led to her making that
decision that after eight years you know
she had if there was something else that
happened in Spain with other patients or
and or anything medical that happened
with her that made her chicks decide
this is a very good point because really
i don't know i have asked the doctors
the doctor that was carrying taking care
of immaculada but what have happening
because she has been on ventilation for
such a long time and then suddenly see
the side no I am tired I don't want and
they say that it's not clear because she
had been a saying for the last two years
he has been speaking about this so see
what I mean that she was thinking about
this but she had not taken a clear
decision
in this moment so see how to stress this
lets him have not done an advance
directive so it was not clear about this
and one moment see decides this and I
mean I mean that the doctors are not
telling me completely the truth because
probably at work more because i have to
say that immaculada was in a Catholic
hospital although although the defunding
of his Karim was from the state it was a
Catholic hospital i'm probably at sun at
some more at one moment she began to say
i want to be disconnected and somebody
told him we cannot do that and i think
and then she takes the decision to
invite the journal the depressed and to
give a talk about her decision and this
is the starting point of all the debate
but i agree with you it's it sounds
strange but she was she was clearly
capable because she was evaluated by two
independent psychiatrist about capacity
but i don't know really that was a
future shock and his works out to
imagine you as having seen that news
yeah probably the world the debate in
spain in the last five years about these
topics has be very intense and maybe
that is he was influenced by the Ramon
Sampedro case or the movie or when it
was there was a lot of cases in this
time i don't i don't know i wish it
did you have politicians trying to take
advantage of it for their own benefit
way we did here with the Terri Schiavo
case well and I have to say first that
the first reaction of politicians was we
cannot do that this was the first
reaction but after some people mean for
sample and others began to call I mean
that is not so clear that we cannot do
that because my opinion and the opinion
of father like me were this is awesome
this is allowed by the law so they began
to change the politicians and they and
they help the the the decision of of
immaculada at the end and they take
advantage of this you know a politician
by definition take advances always of
these type of things but I mean that in
this in this case was in favor of the
liberty of the freedom of a basement it
was fine in this case for example in the
case of the lega nails of the palliative
sedation the politicians worm because
there was a fight ideological fight
behind because the doctors and the
hospital of laganas were members of the
left wing and the politicians in madrid
were members of the right wing and so
under behind the debate about palliative
sedation was also a political question
and it was a pity because this is to use
the patience and the suffering of people
for ideological debate and this is not
fine this is not moral my opinion
i don't know i am going to follow one
two three and four okay
he made a distinction between
existential suffering if there's some
things that if someone because it's like
with Ramon Sampedro you could argue he
wasn't in pain he was he couldn't feel
his body but his brain was completely
active he was very social like he was
his family cared for him he was in set
you know like he was in an environment
but he was suffering existentially in
that that was his issue he couldn't like
psycho his pain would she it's hard
sometimes i don't know what i want to
make the distinction between
psychological and physical pain because
i think that's there yeah i think
there's just pain but i find that in a
lot of these decisions people make that
distinction i'm wondering what what your
committee thought or what you think yeah
important I mean well you can say
physical this so physical psychological
side or existential or existential or
spiritual sadly it is no easy to
differentiate but for example today I I
mean I mean that is is not acceptable is
not acceptable most of the cases to
accept that a person is asking me to
help him or her to die because he is
suffering physical pain there are some
cases because it's difficult to control
pain in some cases but most of the cases
we can have a very good control of the
pain and so and this is related with
other thing that in one of the assassins
of your masters you were discussing
about this and i am going to give my
opinion it's about this world
what is dignity and you told dignity is
not a very clear world in fact you can
read that there is an article by drove
making the British Medical Journal is a
dignity is not a useful is something
like that I said yo slip I disagree with
that because I think it's a very use
useful comfort but I have to splain how
to understand the concept of dignity
because the problem with the concept of
dignity is that then maybe you have to
use the concept in three different sense
of all levels there are three different
ways of understanding the concept of
dignity or to use the concept of dignity
the first dignity is a formal concept
this is an so what we are saying about
human beings is that they have dignity
this means just that they cannot be used
only as means but also as ends this is
the categorical principle but this is
just formal because is not speaking
about well but what is that can they say
you know so this is like a glove like a
glove I don't have here my clothes wait
so the question is that the formal
concept of dignity is it like it like a
play like a theatre play here it is the
formal concept of dignity is this now
the problem is which is the best hand to
give content to this growth so what that
really means to treat the persons with
dignity what is that i can say that of
course I say that a person's heart
dignity and can sense because they are
why why they have dignity in this sense
and can will say because they are they
have reason they have rationality and
this is the difference with the animals
for example so you can from a Kantian
perspective you cannot say that animals
have dignity in this sense because they
are not rational we can discuss this of
course for simply that in the in the in
the English tourism really the concept
of Lee of dignities mobilink related not
not to rationality but to emotions for
sampling him the point is to have or not
to have feelings to have or not the
capacity to experiment pain who is Chris
experiment in pain is able to feel and
then has dignity and this is the open
door to rear ended 2 to the vindication
of animal rights but this is a formal
cordon now we can discuss what is
dignity with content content material so
what is what is to respect the dignity
of the person really well now there is a
general agreement i can say that that is
for example to respect human rights
so the way to respect to gift to the
best hand now there is Han about dignity
the best had to give content to the idea
of dignity is respecting human rights
probably a in the next century we will
have other contents and the last is this
is four overs for the people and the
first level is dignity for me so how can
i with respect in my dignity this is my
question I am the only one who can
decide when I am respect with dignity
and this connect with what you were
asking so nobody can says the other you
are not suffering no no no I have to say
that if I am suffering for a physical
psychological or spiritual point of view
okay I have one two three and four
physicians in hospitals and has there
been resistance from patients or
patients families yes yes yes of course
and easy so this law studies afraid work
by now the debate continues so not all
the funny but I need that for sample men
can even without presenting now or even
in a problem now until now the conflict
means that well I think this is your
time but if the family wants I am NOT
going to look for problems so I'm going
to continue with mechanical ventilation
until the end so this is the way that
many physicists have been thinking until
now probably even now many cases are
doing that but I mean that the framework
is allowing them to to take the decision
in another way feeling because because
you feeling more safe this is going to
change the real way in which spice and
elution doctors are taking the scissors
yeah thank you for the fascinating
lecture and don't think I'm alone in
saying that your ability to express the
concept is crystal clear issue you
should be completely confident thank you
so much too quickly the framework you
were describing for euthanasia
specifically requires that it is
performed by a healthcare professional
is there a civil or criminal procedure
legislation in in the event that it is
somebody who is not a healthcare
professional with the relationship with
that individual yes yes because you know
that the penal code is not speaking
about professionals this was an
introduction of the of the andalucian
law a definition of filth in Asia but if
for example is the doctor that was
issued and was punished as criminal
offense in the only case it was a doctor
but it could be not a doctor
because the criminal called dozen states
that has to be a professional this is a
proportion of the undulation law okay so
one more okay is there any kind of
address about resources in terms of
therapeutic obstinacy assume with your
Ernie or shipping interest to public
health framework yeah there is a big
discussion here about individual rights
versus public health rights and based on
the circumstances of the environment
whether to provide those resources
changes when resources become more
constrained yeah right so in the example
you were just describing if an
individual wants the care even though
it's futile if there are more resources
the doctor can say okay we'll give it to
them you know to write out the years but
then if there's a public health
emergency or something like that we got
that we cut it and there would be and
there would be less liability concerns
for that dog yeah this is very
interesting very interesting well I i
like i like to separate the ugly the
professional obligations of doctors in
relation with what is indicated or not
indicated because it is futile I mean
this is one part and the second part is
that these decisions have economic
consequences always but I would say that
you cannot decide if a treatment is
indicated or not with the argument that
it is too expensive so the reason what I
am deciding to limit the treatment is
because because it is not indicated
that's all all that I I know that if I
consider that the treatment is not
indicated and I am doing it I am NOT
doing limitation the hassle for example
in a public in the intestinal system has
very important consequences that I am
NOT I am wasting the money in an
inappropriate way but the main reason is
not this this is a second
argument the first is which are my
obligation as professional you know
although i think that this all the
weights in a crisis in a crisis moment
will go more involved with the
economical arguments I mean some
politicians again will have here their
paper to do the role to play of course
sir I will tell you in when dear because
the the Spanish situation is critical i
was under the singing of argan oil
shales set for eight years current
account at some point that she fell she
will encompass relatives coming to visit
all entire she totally unable she's very
full time and related by the four years
ago in materials all the people walking
in taxes is documentation or stroking
and they probably know with their wives
at all contemplating suicide try and
they and did indicate a long way since
they had the stroke and here's someone
who had coding a capacity for eight
years pushy and said hey I family really
come on in play I don't know if I can
follow Jesus our income like
him because here I am in a reputation
yeah yeah well I mean for example that
in the United States you know that the
lighting culture and even in other
cultures different to the more liberal
culture in the United in coming in the
United States on even indian anglo-saxon
countries the family is very very very
important in Spain and even for other
cultures and and the family plays a very
important role this is the reason why
all these decisions are so so difficult
because sometimes you have to fight
against a huge amount of values feelings
where the families are involved in the
in the care of day of the patient and so
it's not easy I mean will be the last
one I have a question about the assisted
suicide now you're from Spain and there
I understand there's a lot of different
legislation all over Europe we have the
Netherlands we have Belgium we have the
assisted suicide on legal in in
Switzerland which is not part of the
communion but anyway in Europe so the
question from years has there ever been
an attempt on the European legislative
side in stress work on Bruce and
Brussels to to form a more and sanctuary
for this especially since the first
child of the first article of the China
is called dignity yeah yeah very good
very good question very difficult very
difficult you know you know I mean that
probably that I you have to have debates
between the different states here in the
United States and and and to and to find
an agreement at the federal level is not
easy but in Europe Wow
because the traditions are so different
the language section is so different the
cool for example I have been involved in
some discussions in Brussels about this
in workshops with different european
countries about this and is so difficult
for example the eastern countries the
way of thinking is so different to the
Western countries and the sulfur
countries are so different than norm
countries that is very different to find
an agreement for sample this this this
recommendation that I showed you about
advance directives in the Council of
Europe it took four years to reach to a
single document that is telling so
simple things but it's important because
now many countries have to develop
advanced electives like they have not
yet but for other countries is clearly
insufficient because they are for a way
of of this orderly society is very diff
is very difficulty in Europe to to to do
this and well the point of of the
Netherlands and valium along in
euthanasia you know that the situation
in Europe is Netherlands Belgium and
Luxembourg euthanasia okay assisted
suicide in the Netherlands and insulin
and now the United Kingdom is going to
probably regulate assisted suicide so
this is a situation so how to deal with
this question in an environment European
you environment while you have the
sulfur or the instr countries that are
completely against this so it's very
difficult really okay and I mean this
the last question
60 years ago most doctors would continue
treatment no matter what and a lot of
the battles and bioethics were too for
families to get their doctors to what
stop treating and that that's that's
happened I think and what I'm beginning
to see and this is anecdotal perhaps not
not research is that we've gone the
other direction where there are now
families who are very unhappy that the
doctors are trying to talk them into
taking their page their loved ones off
life support and this is why it's a very
tricky thing it was one of your question
marks when the family wants it the
doctor thinks it's futile but it has to
be a real accommodation I mean and there
also we have religious exemptions if you
are if you're a certain religion you can
be left on life support even if the
doctor feels is futile because you have
a religious exemption and I just I just
wanted if there's any sense of that did
that happen in Spain is that you mr.
Catholic country may be a very different
situation I mean well I have to say that
probably the station in his penis that
we have both problems now so just do to
10 years ago the problem was that
doctors won't wanted to continue on the
family were saying stop stop stop and
now we have the contrary problem because
many doctors want to stop and the
families as I no no no so we have of
problems in Spain so there are
situations in which doctors are doing
therapeutic obstinacy but this is easier
because now the framework is more clear
but the other problem is not so easy I
mean it's the saying that in a in here
and religious receptions the framework
did you were a framework that does not
contemplate these I does think about
this but I mean that fatal disease as
all decision-making medicine
has to be very pregnant a very
deliberative at the end and and I can
justify exceptions for many things you
can do for example you think in a in a
teenager with non-hodgkin lymphoma
terminal and then you decide to stop to
put blood okay until now would you have
been using blood because this has the
this water to recover but now do you
begin to consider that it is a fertile a
futile treatment because his terminal I
am going not to give blood but then the
family tells you tells you please we
know that we are at the end but we have
to wait because his father is in the
United States he has to come here can
you put blood again you know that it is
futile from a strictly clinical sense of
view but I mean that you and me we could
use blood again one week to give the
father to come and to say goodbye but
what if in the next week the mother
tells you oh the blood was so fine we
are going to use it again what could you
say
I could say I'm sorry no because we are
at the end and we have to prepare for
the end not to give blood again and
again and again and again so we can use
the sections but we have to be able to
justify exceptions and one exceptions
ends with that exception I can not
prolong that okay